[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, my name is Eren, and
I'm the product manager
for Webnak, which is a
logistics marketplace
application in Turkey.
Right now, through Webnak,
we send a push notification
to all the truck drivers
regarding the shipments.
So let's say if you have
100 shipments per day,
100 notifications go to
all the truck drivers that
are registered in our system.
That may be good, or
annoying, for some of them,
but it will be a problem when
we have 1,000 shipments per day.
To fix that, we try to
come up with an intelligent
notification system.
We will look at the
location of the truck driver
plus his or her interests.
If a truck driver is
interested in a city, which
we see that from
their previous bids,
we will send the notification
to the truck driver.
Or, if he's close to
the loading place,
if he's close to
the destination,
again, it would be important
for the truck driver,
so we'll still send
the notification.
So these technological
changes helped
us scale our business
from 100 shipments a day
to 1,000 shipments per day.
It even-- it will
grow even bigger.
[MUSIC PLAYING]